Jim, where are you, what's going on?
Thanks so much, it is great to be here.
Thank you for having me, Conan.
Oh, for God's sake, don't--
It's good to be here.
I'm a big fan of your,
uh, (clears throat) show.
Okay, you have it on a, it
says show on a piece of paper?
That's the idea, really?
It says show.
Okay, uh-huh.
Hold on excuse me.
Okay.
Yes?
All right, no, no.
Yes, just a minute.
No, no.
Yes.
You're talking into a zucchini.
Yes, he is wearing the
shirt of a 12-year-old boy.
(Conan and Jim laughing)
We've got a lot to talk about.
We've known each other, I
think for over 60 years.
65.
65 years.
What is that, is that urine in a jar?
I've been busy today.
So you're urinating into a jar on Zoom?
These are human eyeballs.
Oh for God...
This is, I had some dilly
beans from Aunt Martie,
a friend of mine who makes,
he sent me some of these,
these dilly beans, amazing.
Okay, okay.
Sorry, go on.
No, no, no, no.
This is all gold.
Wait a minute,
who put these stairs here?
Oh, look at that.
You got some stairs there?
It's hard to, that's the
laziest going down stairs
I've ever done because I don't want
to move out of my chair, and
I don't have the quad strength
so I'm just gonna do it while
remaining in a chair you know?
It's ridiculous.
How are you, Jim, we've
known each other, as I said,
for like 60 years and we've
liked each other for months.
Yes.
How are you holding up
in quarantine, how are
you doing, old friend?
Yeah, I just want, I'm here with my family
which I love them dearly.
And I just want, I want
someone to go to bed.
I'm tired, nobody goes to sleep.
It used to be people would go to bed.
I'm the only one that goes to bed.
I nap during the day
and I'm still the first one
to go to bed, I'm tired.
Yeah, I know you have a very large family.
How many people we talking here?
How many kids do you got?
There are five children,
and they're just--
And no one sleeps, no one goes to bed.
No one actually sleeps.
They don't go to sleep.
They're just, they're like my wife.
They don't need sleep, they wanna talk.
They wanna do things.
It's like, I don't know, I
shouldn't have had a family.
I don't know if it's too
late now, but I still...
No, there's still things you could do.
They're not legal, they're not moral,
but we can talk when
this interview is over.
There's still a way out.
Remember when you told me
you thought Scott Peterson
was a good guy, you remember that?
(Conan laughing)
Yeah, yeah, I remember
going on at great length
about how one of the--
You said that guy who
killed his pregnant wife
was a good guy and I
was like, "No, Conan."
Yeah, I said, "That guy just," I said,
"He feels like a quality,
quality chum, he does."
That's what I said.
Yeah.
Do you think that was a mistake?
I think that's wrong,
do you know what I mean?
Okay, okay, so what are you doing?
You're not sleeping.
You've got at last count 15
kids, a wife that won't sleep.
You must be losing your mind.
Is there anything that gives you peace
during these strange times we're in, Jim?
I spend time in my garden.
That never used to happen before.
And you know what I like about my garden
is my family's not there.
That's a sweet--
That's what I like about my garden.
That's really sweet.
Hold on, hello.
Okay, no.
Yeah.
The interview's, I don't know how long.
I'm just phoning it in,
don't worry, I'll be done.
Okay, I love you, too.
The zucchini bit, this
is something you're--
The zucchini bit, I
always go to it, you know.
You're--
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
This is a big phone
call, hello? (chuckles)
Yeah, no, it's not working,
none of the bits are.
No, okay, hold on.
Can I say something?
Are these, these must be
coming from your garden.
Is that right?
Is that why you have all
these massive vegetables?
Yes, these are, and by the way,
do you remember in "Happy Days"
when Ralph Malph used to
say, "I still got it."
Mm-hmm.
I don't go it.
He'd go, "I still got it."
I still got it.
I don't got it anymore.
Why would a young child be wondering
if he's still got it anyway?
I just, I don't know.
I don't know how to answer that question
'cause I just noticed that
they put makeup on my face
but I'm wearing a short-sleeved shirt
and they didn't touch my arms
and the disparity is shocking
between my face and my arm.
This is a clown show here.
I'm in an abandoned theater
and I look like Lorenzo Lamas
except my arms look like
they've had chemotherapy.
I don't know what's
happening and I apologize.
And you're in a steak
restaurant or some kind of--
I'm in a steakhouse, and
when Wilmer Valderrama
finds out you took his
shirt, he's gonna be upset.
Okay, okay, you win, you win.